et l'annoncé ce weekend de benoît hamon
keeps le parti socialiste devant onze
mille personnes réunies sur la pelouse
de reuilly à paris l'ancien député des
yvelines a lancé dans la foulée la
création de son mouvement du 1er juillet
son objectif est de dépasser les parties
reconstruire la gauche écoutez le
je quitte ce parti parce que j'ai acquis
l'intimé conviction que je serais plus
utile en dehors de celui-ci
et nous avons
désormais la responsabilité de faire re
vivre et de faire vivre cet idéal auquel
tant d'entre nous sacrifie temps de leur
temps parmi vous des milliers je crois
plus que jamais à la nécessité du combat
socialiste celui qui associe la conquête
des libertés la conquête des droits
sociaux alors